bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de venom de et plus
particulièrement de sa scène post
générique donc d'entrée voilà vous êtes
avertis la vidéo va spoil sévère le film
et du coup bah ça c'est le post
générique donc voilà si vous n'avez pas
vu venom 2 c'est très déconseillé de
voir cette vidéo bon en vrai il ya
vraiment plein de choses à dire et je
suis curieux d'avoir votre ressenti sur
tout ça mais bon bref ne tardons pas
comment son on en parlait il y a un
petit moment maintenant mais c'était
quand même bizarre cette sortie de b
nomme deux situés juste avant spider man
no way home surtout que la communication
de sony autour de ça et est particulière
car si on se rappelle un peu ça parlait
beaucoup de spider man de son voyage etc
mais au final pas tant que ça de venom
il y avait juste les traileurs alors que
pourtant son film sortait et bientôt et
avant new way home bref c'était suspect
mais maintenant nous avons les réponses
venom sera dans spider man nos héros
bien jouer sony dans une scène post
générique ou eddie brock et venom sont
en cavale entre guillemets suite aux
évènements du deuxième film nous
retrouvons ces derniers dans une chambre
d'hôtel une chambre qui va se
métamorphoser et qui va nous donner
l'impression d'un changement de réalité
eh bien c'est ce qui semble être le cas
puisque par le biais de la télévision
nous voyons qu eddie et venom ont voyagé
à travers les réalités pour se retrouver
dans celle du mc hugh ou peter est en
plein drame had médiatique concernant la
mort de mystérieux et d'ailleurs même
dans le visuel nous retrouvons les codes
instaurer du m6 où il y as genre une
sorte de réécriture de la réalité ou les
meubles et les objets ont un effet de
bugs de glitch exactement que on en
avait été témoin dans rwanda vision ce
qui appuie donc l'idée que doctor
strange avec son sort a tenté de
réécrire la réalité pour effacer
l'identité de peter dans la tête des
gens et en s'appuyant donc sur d'autres
réalités ou justement personne ne
connaissent pas et norman ou bien bas il
n'y a pas de spider man hasard ou pas il
n'y a jamais eu la présence d'un spider
man dans la réalité de venom des films
de sony l'idée que dr strange est choisi
cette réalité pour corriger la
révélation de l'identité de peter n'est
pas à négliger et du coup par extension
la présence de venom dans le mc ou est
une conséquence du sort raté de strange
qui auraient fusionné plusieurs réalités
entre elles donc voilà je suis désolé
mais ça appuie encore l'idée de
l'arrivée d'un tobey maguire ou d'un
andrew garfield aka que nous avons déjà
traité plusieurs fois mais bon puisque
cela a pu arriver à venom et bien il n'y
a aucune raison que cela n'arrive pas
aux deux anciens spade surtout qu'en
plus nous retrouvons les méchants de
leur réalité bref néanmoins cela nous
donne plein de choses à analyser et
théorisé puisque déjà par rapport au
trailer de noël comme nous pouvons le
confirmer il s'agissait bien de venom
qui attaquent peter dans le noir le
doute était clairement permis entre si
c'était le lézard ou venom et nous
semblons avoir la réponse ce qui écarte
du coup la possible présence du lézard
dans les si mr 6 mais on n'est à l'abri
de rien encore il pourrait y avoir les
deux néanmoins du coup il faut parler du
rôle de venom qui est un cas assez
particulier est-ce qu'il sera au final
un méchant ou pas et bien c'est assez
délicat et je pense que disney et sony
vont tenter de jouer sur cette ambiguïté
puisque bas à venom est une sorte d'anti
héros où il peut être très violent ou
agressif le fait qu'ils mangent des
têtes n'aide pas non plus mais dans le
fond venom dépend surtout de son hôte si
son hôte est une mauvaise personne cela
va influencer venom et inversement si
c'est une bonne personne venom
s'adaptera donc voilà eddie brock on
sait ce n'est pas une mauvaise personne
et il est le héros de sa saga d'ailleurs
la fin de venom 2 semble encore plus
poussée et d'y et venom à devenir encore
plus héroïque cependant le trailer nous
indique qu'il y aura quand même des
confrontations entre speedy et venom
puisque ce dernier dans le noir tentent
d'attaquer peter et par rapport à la
scène post générique de venom de venom
semble trouver un intérêt tout
particulier chez peter et ce sont à mon
sens des éléments importants car peter
parker a beau être un héros eddie brock
joué par tom hardy
mais aussi et bien cela ne veut pas dire
qu'ils vont forcément s'entendre nous en
avons déjà eu la preuve avec des films
comme civil war pour aller plus dans le
détail peter est la cause de la
mésaventure des 10 et évidemment cela va
jouer sur les tensions entre les deux
personnages mais pas que puisque si
venom dans le mc huismes il y à l'arc de
la relation entre venom et spider man
sera adapté dans le mc vous le savez
tous la relation entre benno et spider
man est un événement très important de
l'histoire des deux personnages
notamment par le biais des comics pour
venom spider man est l'hôte parfait et
pour cause grâce à la symbiose entre lui
et son hôte venom à la capacité
d'assimiler les propriétés de la
personne sur laquelle il est ce qui veut
dire que si venom réussi à s'emparer de
peter parker il va assimiler ses
pouvoirs et les conserver et ça pour moi
c'est un point hyper important pour le
développement de venom puisque dans le
modèle de développement des rôles ces
derniers évoluent toujours vers une
version améliorée de même que ce soit
mentalement ou physiquement nous pouvons
prendre pour exemple directement le cas
de speedy qui au tout début était la
simple araignée du quartier et qui au
final au fil du temps s'est vu attribuer
de nouvelles beit comme le sens
d'araignée qui s'est réveillé le costume
d'iron spider ou encore la technologie
est dit pour ne citer qu'eux et bien
pour venom c'est pareil eddie brock et
venom sont loin d'avoir fini leur
parcours se fit entre sony et marvel
n'est pas la fin au contraire et on se
doute même qu'il y aura un venom 3 un
jour ou l'autre sauf que pour continuer
à nous proposer de lille brock eddie
brock et inédit broc bref de la
nouveauté l'évolution car il ne faut pas
que les personnages stagne et bien il va
falloir faire avancer venom et là
l'occasion est beaucoup trop belle avec
noé rom pour que venom puissent
interagir avec peter parker et du coup
récupérer ses pouvoirs je suis même
presque prêt à parier que c'est l'une
des nombreuses raisons du fit donc si
l'on suit cette logique venom
obtiendrait le pouvoir de s'accrocher au
mur comme une araignée une force encore
plus puissante et surtout le spyder
sense possiblement la faculté la plus
puissante de spider man néanmoins un
petit bémol sur les toiles puisque celle
du peter parker du m6 où est le résultat
d'une expérience chimique etc tisseur de
toile sont simplement technologiques en
revanche si eddie peut s'intéresser à
peter car il est à l'origine de sa
mésaventure et que venom semble être
attiré par spider man possiblement à
cause de ses pouvoirs et bien la fin
peut justifier les moyens nous pourrions
avoir un venom qui joue sur les deux
plans ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'on sait et venom ne sera pas le seul
dans cette situation puisque le retour
d'octopus d'électro ou encore le bouffon
vert sont véritablement confirmé tous
ses personnages seront dans le même
bateau perdu dans une autre réalité avec
un problème commun et vu comment venom a
changé de réalité on se doute que le
procédé a dû être le même pour les
autres tout ça pour dire qu'il
semblerait logique de venom s'allie au
sinistre 6 dans la première partie du
film et c'est là que c'est intéressant
puisque dans les comics venom a fait
équipe avec les sinistres 6 un court
moment donné donc il ya de la cohérence
dans tout ça sauf que voilà on connaît
le eddie brock des films venom venom en
lui même ils ne sont pas hostiles du
tout et les fortes à parier qu'au vu des
actions des autres vilains ces derniers
du coup se retourne face aux sinistres 6
pour justement aider et sauver la
population d'ailleurs autre point
important c'est qu'il dit et venom ont
besoin de peter et de strange pour
justement résoudre la situation et
rentrer chez eux donc en soi il n'y a
pas de véritable raison qu'il se
combattent à part pour assimiler les
pouvoirs de speedy et c'est là qu'un
autre point intéressant fait surface
puisque dans les comics face à la menace
carnage qui est trop grande spider man
et venom mettent de côté leurs conflits
pour arrêter leur ennemi commun un
parallèle que nous pourrions retrouver
face aux sinistres six qui sont de
véritables menaces pour tout le monde
néanmoins il y à un autre cas que
j'aimerais traité c'est celui de tobey
maguire effectivement je suis un
partisan du fait qu'il y aura tobey
maguire et andrew garfield pour diverses
raisons que nous avons déjà abordé comme
la vision marketing de sony le spyder
verse l'évolution de peter parker et
caetera et c est justement par le biais
de la présence de tobey maguire et bien
il y a une certaine cohérence à
respecter puisque ce dernier a déjà
partagé ses pouvoirs avec un venom et a
combattu un eddie brock qui était en
symbiose avec le symbiote alors oui peut
exister la possibilité que si toby
maguire il y a ils viennent d'une autre
temporalité par exemple spider man 2 où
il n'a pas encore justement combattu
non mais j'ai du mal à y croire puisque
le bouffon vert est présent et
normalement bas ce dernier est mort
avant que octavius ne devienne octopus
et pourtant ils sont tous les deux là et
pour le bon développement du film un
toby mcguire vétéran qui a beaucoup
d'expérience et qui vient les partager
aux peter parker de du mc eu bat c'est
beaucoup plus impactants est plus
intéressant qu'un reese est totalement
random du personnage bref du coup si
toby il y à ce dernier reconnaîtra
forcément le symbiote et mettra en garde
le peter parker du mc ou un paramètre
intéressant qui pourrait tendre encore
plus les héros entre eux comme je le
disais tout à l'heure mais surtout toby
contrairement aux peter de andrew et de
tom holland est le seul à posséder le
pouvoir de tisser des toiles vu que les
deux autres utilisent ce qu'ils
appellent des web shooters et c'est un
paramètre qui peut clairement intéressés
venom encore plus que pour le peter de
tom holland cependant toby sait comment
neutraliser le symbiote et c'est quelque
chose qui freinera forcément et dix
événements bon il faut au moins qu'on
termine sur la problématique du costume
noir et or présent dans le trailer il
est vrai que normalement la couleur
noire sur un costume de spider man c'est
une référence directe aux symbiote
normal néanmoins ici il pourrait
simplement s'agir de la spyder armor
m.gates ou un costume noir et or que
speedy a conçu pour compenser la perte
de son spider sense en soi c'est un
costume très peu connue qui pourrait
être remanié dans le mc hugh mais marvel
et sony aime les références on se
rappelle de certains easter egg comme
par exemple celui du fist et donc par
extension de mr négative la question est
légitime de se poser en vrai mais il
semblerait qu'il s'agisse simplement
d'un nouveau costume nous savons que
peter va continuer d'évoluer et
l'utilisation d'un nouveau costume est
un bon moyen visuels de le montrer
surtout que dans la symbolique peter
reporte le costume conçu par tony stark
tony est temps mort la création d'un
costume fait à 100% par peter n'est pas
anodin et cela correspond à l'origine de
la spyder armor m kate ou en revanche le
costume d'iron spyder semble toujours
resté principal pour la jeune araignée
la venue d'un autre costume impliquera
forcément des raisons particulières au
vu du marketing liées aux jouets il se
pourrait que le costume soit lié à la
magie et donc par extension a doctor
strange
enfin voila c'était une vidéo dédiée à
la scène post générique de venom de et
j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu on a
traité de pas mal de choses et de
questions déjà mais ne vous inquiétez
pas il ya encore beaucoup à traiter en
vrai de vrai c'est un gros coup de génie
de la part de sony d'implémenter venom
dans le mc hugh et je pense très
clairement que nous sommes très loin
d'être au bout de nos surprises en fait
nous ne connaissons pas véritablement la
profondeur des accords entre marvel et
sony et personnellement je trouve que la
question la plus dure à répondre ces
quatre viendra-t-il 2
peter et du coup de venom aussi à la fin
de nos héros mme car au vu des accords
excès liés aux accords et bien tout est
possible est ce que peter à la fin de
nos et home se perdra dans le multivers
afin de créer une absence cohérente pour
la saga en fonction des accords est-ce
que venom retrouvera le chemin de la
maison est ce qu'il restera ou
reviendra-t-il dans le m6 où on le
rappelle quand même mais bon spider man
no et home pas de retour à la maison
voilà quoi le titre n'est pas du tout
aléatoire je vous rappelle que nous
sommes complètement à l'aube du
multivers et si ces questions sont très
difficiles à répondre c'est parce que
spider man là ça ne dépend plus
simplement du scénario mais cela dépend
aussi de la vraie vie des désaccords
quoi donc voilà tout est clairement
possible dans tous les cas je vous
conseille de vous abonner à la chaîne
car la seconde bande annonce de noé home
arrive très bientôt et du coup par
extension bas son lot de théories qui va
avec si la vidéo vous a plu je vous
invite également à me laisser un petit
pouce bleus 1 ça fait toujours plaisir
c'est un petit soutien et puis à me dire
ce que vous avez pensé de venom
de sa scène post générique et c'est de
tout ce que ça implique en commentaire
j'ai très hâte de vous retrouver pour de
belles vidéos théorie sachez que j'ai
pas mal d'idées en ce moment donc voilà
écoutez que le lie à notre art soit avec
vous cet argot rock ali chiao tung
[Musique]